so it's like three and a half being
three and a half pinkies so what's half
of three and a half pinkies why am i
helping you
Francois oh we doing man what's up I'm
Kevin and today I'm challenging my
coworkers to see who can cut a piece of
paper perfectly in half closest to the
center gets $100
it's the perfect cut challenge perfect
cut challenge welcome to the perfect cut
challenge perfect cut yeah I don't see
scissors do you know what that means I'm
gonna cut something real nice you are
wearing a lot of red today I felt very
ready for this challenge
okay leave the puns to me thank you
there's a lot of pressure on you right
now yeah if your mother was that good
make my family proud oh I would not want
to be in your shoes so all you have to
do is take this perfectly normal sheet
of eight-and-a-half by eleven paper cup
and cut it perfectly in half what's the
catch you're good I'm guessing I can
fold it nope can I use a table as a mark
here some sort like this I'm gonna say
next
you only get one shot okay no do-overs
okay oh and last thing you gotta use
kids scissors oh you disrespectful now I
didn't expect that that's why it's the
perfect cut challenge I challenge the
person who gets the closest to a perfect
half gets $100 cash money out of my
wallet oh my god from your wallet my I
don't want that money if it's not from
your wallet so you just carry it yeah I
just carry $100 in my pocket because
that's a straddle
got you don't want to do it that money
what are you gonna do with it
tacos baby gotta get that taco money son
I I'll just give it to my son I don't
know just take it hundred dollars on the
table are you ready for the perfect cut
challenge I am ready for the perfect cut
challenge part of the challenge so
what's your strategy um go slow I think
is the strategy okay yeah
do you have steady hands I do not but
I'm gonna just I'm gonna meditate and
we've got this okay we don't have all
day
so we're gonna figure out where the
middle point is that would happen I flip
it over doesn't know what I'll line it
up with this corner over here and I'm
gonna use my thumb for measurement okay
I kinda wanna use my hand okay
oh you have a good there too there what
I'm doing is sighing oh you're coming
from the top down I think that's an easy
way to see the center okay this is two
three three fat hands big what doesn't
look AJ that we don't have all day
okay so this is my technique taught me
hopefully it works with this paper cuz I
did it with wrapping paper mm-hmm but I
don't you Oh God I've made it I've made
a cut
don't turn your back are you sure are
you sure yes oh okay
I am making the cut
it's not working though I thought I was
gonna do it really well
yeah I don't get it right it doesn't
want to be right this is gonna take 16
years
it's like watching bread rise see other
people are like trying to measure and
stuff like that wrong I'm not that
committed to this all right
wow that was so good you think those are
pretty good I think oh we messed up we
messed up what are you doing jasmine
[Music]
why the hell am I making faces I'm
cutting this I'm not sure
[Music]
okay I don't think it's perfect
[Music]
that was a journey oh my god I'm not bad
Wow all right very decisive you think
you did not so well I think I did pretty
well I'm sure there's a slight curve but
I think overall I think I've made two
pretty even pieces what do you think
it's not straight either am i wait I
just got that cool yeah cool hmm this is
the overlay the overlay is perfectly
overlay does not line the red line why
they're those cross lines yes wonderful
okay so you're gonna be judged by the
side that has your name on it I'm gonna
line it up with the clean edges he's
doing stop it stop it it's different
made it worse listen I'm the judge okay
all right whoa look at it
whoa that's probably the best so far
oh yeah it's not a disaster but it's not
great it's not great Wow payday I mean
it was it's not perfect cut but I'm okay
with it you're okay with it because I'm
not oh my god it's so good oh wow it's
beautiful
Shelby it's beautiful Shelby did I win
did I win you gave it a valiant effort
but you didn't do great you know I'll go
home and practice I always do next time
I'll come back ready to win we will
never do this again
okay so the top three contenders are
Adam Devon and George Devon did very
well but this little bit up here may
have cost her Adam did real well
I've got real close the George started
off right of center but then pretty much
hit dead center for the second half but
I think his deviation in the
beginning is more than Adams overall
deviation looks like Adams our winner
let's go get him this money
[Music]
congratulations
I did it you wanted the perfect cut
challenge thank you very much any any
words of wisdom um it's Lois a low
savings race and also your art degree
yeah it has meaning now
[Music]
perfect that challenge